noah manoir bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin dans la matinale de rtl
france alors pour commencer dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes à quelques
heures du début de ce goût de la
sécurité est ce que vous êtes convaincu
absolument pas je ne vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui à l'instant t on aurait des
réformes significatives du
fonctionnement de l'institution
policière mais également la qualité de
service public puisque c'est de ça dont
il s'agit on nous présente ce beau coup
de la sécurité comme un débat sur
l'amélioration en termes de performance
et de qualité et service public de ce
que fournissent les institutions police
et gendarmerie nationale écoutez
monsieur macro et élus en 2017
je crois pas qu'on ait eu d'amélioration
significative de la qualité de service
public bien au contraire
depuis un bout que écouter ici quand
bien même des décisions seraient prises
à l'issue de ce sommet qui est par ce
gouvernement elle serait appliquée par
le gouvernement suivant puisque on
arrive à échéance électorale donc non je
suis absolument pas convaincu à titre
personnel c'est à dire que les on se
souvient de ces fameux 7 péchés capitaux
de la police a formulées par le ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin formation
initiale encadrement feu moyen un lien
avec la population ce diagnostic pour
autant
du ministre de l'intérieur vous le
partagez écoutez on pourra pas faire du
neuf avec du vieux
tous les interlocuteurs qui ont été
désignés pour ce sommet comme étant les
participants à ce débat sont des gens
qui n'ont plus prise avec le terrain
depuis des dizaines d'années pour
certains il ya même un responsable
syndical que je ne nommerai pas parce
que j'ai absolument rien contre lui à
titre personnel mais qui a été détaché
de la police nationale en 1992 pour vous
dire donc si vous voulez ce sont
toujours les mêmes depuis de nombreuses
années à ma connaissance aucune
aucun sondage d'opinion aucune aucun
cahier de doléances n'a été ouvert dans
les commissariats et dans les services
de police entré pas prise
c'est ce qui est prévu non pendant le
boulot de la cde de la sécurité
justement d'aller consulter les
fonctionnaires de police
à écouter il aurait fallu prévoir avant
moi je ne sais pas quand je participe à
un débat en tant que délégué syndical et
que je prétend représenter la masse des
effectifs de police je viens avec un
cahier de doléances ou le bras parce que
gérer j'ai fait mon travail correctement
c'est à dire je suis allé sonder les
personnes qui sont sur le terrain pour
leur demander quelles sont les
problématiques qu'ils rencontrent au
quotidien
et là moi je vois pas où il est question
du lien entre la police et la procution
quand on parle de gratuité des
transports par exemple excusez moi mais
la gratuité des transports c'est un
problème important mais ça concerne les
conditions de travail les avantages en
nature des fonctionnaires de police qui
vecchi qui vont au travail ça concerne
pas les citoyens au quotidien je veux
dire ça n'a absolument rien à voir donc
moi je crois que c'est une façon
d'amadouer les syndicalistes les
syndicats de police qu'on connaît et
qu'on entend depuis des années mais ça
ne concerne ni la population ni les
fonctionnaires de police de terrain qui
sont dans les commissariats ça il ya eu
une polémique il ya quelques jours sur
la présence d'omar sy lez lille qui est
a priori la personnalité préférée des
français donc on voit bien qu'il ya
quand même une logique de récupération
on va dire et les syndicats de police
ont dit si omar sy est présent nom
claque la porte et j'ai pas eu le fin
mot de cette histoire est ce que
aujourd'hui on peut nous dire clairement
si omar sy alors on le sait pas
effectivement encore en tout cas voilà
quel est votre regard sur cet épisode
à concerne omar sy écoutez moi j'ai
approuvé sa prise de position au moment
justement de la sphère blague les
mateurs en juin dernier
effectivement il a eu aucun mot en tant
que personnalité je n'ai pas
représentatif n'est pas élu des français
mais bon il est originaire de trappes
il a quand même une certaine légitimité
à évoquer le lien avec la halle avec la
police entre la police et la population
ont maintenant moi tout ce que j'ai vu
c'est hier sur facebook une publicité
pour la mise en ligne en vod de son film
polisse qui est sorti le 1er avril
pendant prôné confinement donc voilà on
dit est à dire que cette opération ou
beauvau de la sécurité est en fait une
opération de communication qui profite à
tout le monde c'est de dire aux hommes
politiques aux cinéastes aux syndicats
de police
c'est à tout le monde sa population aux
opérations de communication avec
d'autres personnalités à votre
connaissance et les personnalités
habituel des syndicats de police qu'on
connaît qu'on a vus revus dont le
discours n'innove en rien témoin je
pense que malheureusement il n'y a pas
grand chose à attendre à ce à cet
instant si vous voulez de l'échéance
électorale
on ne fait pas des réformes
significatives et importantes quatre ans
après avoir été élu sur un mandat qui va
durer cinq ans mais matériellement ce
n'est pas possible à mettre en place ce
que le ministre a la possibilité de
prendre des mesures fortes mais il
aurait dû les prendre en tant que chef
de la police est pas justement dans la
concertation parce qu'on a bien vu que
les syndicats avec son prédécesseur
christophe castaner sont entrés dans une
logique de confrontation
eux veulent commander ils veulent que
l'institution policière ne change pas
parce que le système tel qu'il est
organisé actuellement leur profite donc
le changement n'est pas alors leur
intérêt si je puis dire c'est que c'est
au ministre nader de prendre les devants
de prendre des mesures impopulaires qui
certes pourrait décevoir les syndicats
de police mais serait profitable à 6 à
la population dans son ensemble ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il aurait finalement mieux pas
fallu une loi de programmation parce que
finalement ces réformes
elles seront mises en oeuvre après 2022
donc après la présidence du d'emmanuel
macron oui tout à fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle raser gratis en politique c'est
à dire que bon en démesure on vote des
budgets qui tombe de toute façon on
n'aura pas à assumer la responsabilité
donc si vous voulez au plan
philosophique c'est pas important
aujourd'hui de faire de la communication
politique de fêtes organisées des
réunions qui le concerne il ya une
couverture médiatique autour de cet
événement mais je suis pas sûr que le
français moyen se sentent concernés par
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les
murs du ministère de l'intérieur
donc il ya possibilité de prendre des
mesures fortes tout de suite qu'on
pourrait mettre en application tout de
suite mais voyez on parle depuis deux ou
trois jours de cette agression sauvage
qui a concerné un adolescent du 15e
arrondissement
ça c'est quelque chose justement qu'on
peut traiter tout de suite immédiatement
au travers d'un certain nombre de
mesures fortes parce que ça concerne les
français si on est capable de mettre en
place un dispositif qui permette de
réprimer je sais pas avec vingt
policiers un pizzaïolo qui va décider
d'ouvrir après l'heure du couvre-feu
aujourd'hui personne ne comprend
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à réprimer ces
bancs de semences pierre dans paris et
qui préoccupe par exemple qui polluent
la vie des parisiens et l'atmosphère en
termes d'accès au si merci beaucoup
noah manoir d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin sur rtl je rappelle que vous êtes
délégué du syndicat vigie police